welcome to Hannity on a busy news night
glad you are with us tonight as
President Trump continues his
international trip abroad look at what's
happening at home America's economy has
now become the envy of the world our
economy firing on all cylinders and for
the first time in 75 years we are energy
independent and a net exporter of energy
our unemployment rate is at its lowest
point since 1969 in fact we're now
seeing record low unemployment for
african-americans Hispanic Americans
Asian Americans women in the workforce
youth unemployment that keeps kids like
me when I was young out of trouble
50-year low and the people that unfairly
suffered the most under the obama-biden
economy they are now the single biggest
beneficiaries of donald trump's low
taxes lessening of burdensome regulation
and his america-first agenda without a
doubt it is an amazing time to be an
American to be looking to advance your
life your career your standard of living
but that is not what you'll ever hear
from the mainstream media mob instead we
get obsessively negative coverage of the
president every second hour of every day
conspiracy theories insults outright
lies always lead the news cycle and for
two and a half years the media has
hysterically and breathlessly reported
lies a hoax surrounding Trump and Russia
so it is no surprise we have a brand new
Pew Research poll that shows Americans
now see fake news as a bigger problem
than terrorism that's their poll
according to Pew Research Center this
country is more worried about fake news
than terrorism so-called climate change
racism sexism even violent crime this is
a major political victory for President
Trump he has exposed the phony news
industry for who they are for the first
time in history an American president
has successfully exposed an abusively
biased corrupt agenda driven press for
who they really are with two simple
words fake new
now Trump has branded the men and women
were actively working as an extension of
the Democratic Party all while
pretending to be journalists the
branding is now permanently tattooed
into these so-called news organizations
and they will forever be remembered
their lies their conspiracy theories by
the American people I don't think they
can ever recover and while Americans are
now aware of the threat that is posed by
fake information by lies conspiracy
theories you still have the rage-filled
Trump aiding media mob that is never
going to slow down you think they'll
admit they're wrong make corrections try
and adjust adapt and listen to the
people they're supposed to serve don't
count on it now during the president's
important trip to Europe while the fake
news smear machine in full gear get this
according to the hills media reporter
Joe Concha the president has received
mostly glowing reviews from the British
press but here at home a much different
picture as per usual we have NBC's chief
conspiracy theorists Rachel Maddow
setting the tone for all of her
colleagues you know hateful baseless
coverage of the president's trip by the
way the ratings are now showing it take
a look so I hope you have enjoyed your
trip to London mr. president Boris
didn't have time for you
all of London turned out unanimously to
basically drop their drawers and moon
you plus on all buildings in London
things designed to embarrass or upset
you were prominently projected and
display I think it's very difficult with
Trump though because he is an egomaniac
and he sees all this as being about him
what's wrong with him
where to begin I mean no but I'm serious
I mean narcissistic personality disorder
but he clearly appears less capable of
sustaining his own thoughts for longer
than four to six seconds I mean I mean
it used to be he couldn't follow anyone
else this conversation now he doesn't
seem to be able to follow his own trying
to have thoughts right now trust me if
if Trump were to cure cancer they would
still hate him now thankfully Americans
see the past the media's hateful lies
they see past it their conspiracy
theories on chair psychology sessions
even according to a CNN poll a majority
of Americans believe that Trump will win
re-election and tonight more good news
for the president and his reelection
campaign it's potential challenger the
sleepy creepy Uncle Joe Biden is facing
a major plagiarism scandal yet again I'm
going to address this in part two of my
monologue tonight first joining us with
more on his analysis of the America's
fake news epidemic we have the hills Joe
concha Joe great column today great
comparison today it's all accurate and
they seem to not be able to control this
rage or psychosis
yeah and in this case though at least
Shaun you have another media the British
media in this case that is quite a
juxtaposition from what we're seeing in
terms of US media you mentioned it
before most of it has been not so much
positive but at least it's been
objective in terms of the president's
visit it doesn't concentrate so much on
the sizzle but the steak it concentrates
on for instance we're talking about
British media the president's
relationship with the Queen his rapport
with her and televisions very powerful
medium it's a visual medium and you saw
the pictures and the optics coming out
of there and it was very good for the
president almost anybody objective at
least can say that that same goes for
his relationship with Teresa May and the
press conference he held and so on but
what we saw here from the US media
besides some of the sound bites you
played from the opinion side the pundit
Reese ID was this obsession with the
Trump baby blimp it was almost like
watching the oj white Bronco in 1994 all
over again every time you turned on
cable news it was like the Michael
avenatti
of a blimps you turn it on you couldn't
get away from the blimp and that's
that was basically being concentrated on
and then finally the obsession with the
protests the protests when Donald Trump
went to Britain in 2018 were infinitely
bigger considerably bigger than they
were this time around and even today
during d-day the 75th anniversary that
it comes tomorrow you still had
protesters and coverage of those
protesters on a day where give it a rest
for one day guys given the sacrifices
that happened 75 years ago in France let
me ask you this I I believe that the
president has successfully exposed them
in a way that nobody else really could
and it's branded it's tattooed on their
foreheads I don't see their brands
recovering do you I think when the
president leaves the stage whatever that
may be whether that be in a year and a
half or six years that this would be
like a lot like the the 87 stock market
crash the 2008 financial crash in terms
of ratings and clicks going away because
many of the media unfortunately have
made him the evil protagonist and when
you take him out of the picture it's
like taking jr. Ewing off of Dallas
there's no more show so yeah
unfortunately if they want to recover in
terms of credibility I'm not saying all
of publications are all news channels
but most of them a lot I would argue
three networks to fake news cable
channels post The Washington Post New
York Times let's start there true i I
still wave my pom-poms for local media
which you know what that still has a lot
of credibility because we never see
opinion being inserted into your local
newscast for instance whether good you
know words Joe it's interesting because
every newsroom in America got the Trump
Russia collusion conspiracy theory hoax
they all fell for it and they missed the
biggest stories about abuse of power
corruption
rigging Hillary's investigation the
dirty dossier the FISA applications
lying and a premeditated fraud on a FISA
Court it's the let's see talk-show hosts
that do all of these things that exposed
it look the the Muller report and what
that expose in terms of there being no
collusion between Trump associates and
Russia that was a death blow to this
industry I'm not saying all again but
many in it you
you've played a clip of Rachel Maddow
before she had her lowest ratings last
month in a very very busy busy news
month the lowest ratings since Trump's
inauguration CNN you see down a double
digits again last month on top of a 26%
loss and audience the month before that
that was a watershed moment when that
report and all the promises that we got
from pundits and even anchors alike that
there absolutely was collusion between
Donald Trump and the Russians and when
that promise wasn't delivered people who
simply have not come back because they
don't trust the messenger anymore Sean
Cho concha thank you from the hill
turning that